[Music]
everybody welcome to our session is the
first time I've done one of these in a
movie theater and the seats look very
comfortable so try not to fall asleep
but if you do there is a full recline
mode apparently and one of the buttons
there so I see a couple have already
taken advantage of this okay so we're
gonna be talking about building a global
data presence with goat with a big table
that's a title and my name is Carter
Paige I'm the engineering lead for cloud
BigTable at Google and today joining us
is gonna be Sebastian doll who is a
principal engineer in the networking
group and docma Carlin who is an early
architect of cloud BigTable and he will
be our DJ during the demos so so we're
talking about moving communication
moving data around the world and moving
data quickly low latency access to data
has always been an important and
valuable thing to leaders and business
and governments etc you back to 4490 BC
fi deputies running the distance from
Marathon to Athens and his last dying
breath announced his victory over the
Persians he fast forward just another
two thousand years and you have victory
over Napoleon at Waterloo and the
Rothschild family at this time had a
famous communication network throughout
Europe their families spread around the
the the continents and in England and
using horses and people and you know
maybe carrier pigeons at this point in
time they transmitted information of the
defeat of Napoleon a full 48 hours
before the Prime Minister's own
messengers got word to them allowing
them to make a run on British British
bonds and increase their already massive
fortune in a very famous case of
information arbitrage just 200 years
later and now you're able to transmit
entire copies of the Library of Congress
around the world in just minutes and
it's a truly amazing accomplishment for
mankind if you think about it even just
20 years ago if you wanted to do this
you'd be better served by throwing
digital tapes in the back of a FedEx
truck
so now you can move this data around
really quickly but the hard part is
actually keeping actual data corpuses in
sync on opposite sides of the planet and
that's a little bit what we're gonna
talk about today so we put out a blog
post this morning we announce that we
actually went GA with the global
replication for cloud BigTable and what
this will allow you to do and we'll go
into more detail in a bit is allow you
to replicate your data between any four
regions around the world so you can have
them two regions two zones in one region
two zones in another region or you could
have one zone in each of four regions so
this gives you data look actually like
this first again so this in addition to
the media access so one of things I want
to point out is this basically gives you
low latency access for each of the
different data points so this means a
smoother experience for your customers
imagine you have your customers in one
one country or one continent and maybe
you have call centers on the other side
of the world if they both have low
latency access to the same data it's
going to be a better experience as we
last lag time when people are calling
the phone there's a bunch of other
applications we'll get into as well
another value here is unified analysis
imagine you're collecting data from a
bunch of different sites or users around
the world
if you don't replicate into a single
place then you have to run ETL jobs with
some some thing to pull it in this just
gets your data within minutes usually in
within seconds effect to a single place
and you can run your analytics workloads
in that in that location
pick one your zones to do for the hats
have a workload and the last thing you
can do is you can you basically get an
out-of-the-box disaster recovery
solution so you put you spent up another
zone that just sits there to be be ready
in case you have a problem and we can
either automatically failover or you can
failover manually yourself and then you
get data localization you specify
exactly where you want the data to live
and this is obviously important for
finance and other sorts of industries
that have strict jurisdictional
restrictions in terms of where the data
sits so today I'm going to talk about
what cloud BigTable is and get into the
details the global replication and how
you can
is it then Sabbagh she's gonna come up
and talk about our global cloud network
the fiber that spans the spans the globe
you probably heard about this a little
bit in our keynotes she's also gonna get
into the software that helps to make it
work and then Doug is going to give us a
demonstration of just to show how easy
it is to actually set up a global data
presence on the stage so and just so
we're not we're not cheating by using
like a small amount of data we're going
to start with 10 terabytes 12 I started
12 terabytes and it takes it's not
instantaneous does take some minutes to
start copying so we're gonna start with
Doug and get that copy set up and then
we'll we'll come back to it later in the
presentation
so hey so I'm Doug I'm one of the
engineers on the cloud BigTable team and
I'm one of the developers of the
replication feature and right Carter
just painted a pretty cool picture right
you put your data anywhere we'll keep it
in sync for you you don't have to do
anything except click a couple buttons
I'm sure some of you are wondering how
true that really is right what are the
asterisks on this announcement do you
have to change your apps that are
running to be safe with replication do
you need to stop your traffic while
you're setting it up do you need to lock
in your topology first and then copy
data into it yourself and can you really
put data anywhere you want or other
restrictions there and it turns out the
answer to all these questions is no you
really you don't have any of these
asterisks we will take care of all of
these things for you and I'm gonna
hopefully show you how easy this is live
on stage it's a terrifying demo to give
but so like hard to mention we've got
12t sitting in Oregon right now and I am
going to click a couple buttons and
we're gonna copy it if you want to go to
the next slide to South Carolina Finland
and Taiwan and with any luck it's gonna
be done by the time I come back up in 20
or 30 minutes so in order to get this
started we're just going to go over -
can we get the demo up you go over to
the Edit instance page and I want to
emphasize this is the edit instance page
not to create insta
Paige right you're able to change this
whenever you want and all you have to do
is add clusters to your instance every
cluster is a set of nodes in a zone and
every cluster in your instance serves
every table and if you change your mind
later deletes are also safe will hold
that data behind the scenes for you
until it's safely copied out so I'm just
gonna add a couple clusters here right
first US East one that's South Carolina
and then we're gonna add Europe north
one which is Finland and then we're
gonna add Asia East one which is Taiwan
and then I'm just gonna hit save and now
we're done right I can leave so this is
gonna spin for a couple seconds I'm
gonna show you what's actually going on
right so we're back on the instance
overview and we see already we've got
four clusters here we've got some
spinners over here a couple of them
already finished
that's for provisioning nodes and what
this means is as soon as the spinner is
done you can create a new table and
start using it right away
right these clusters are happy to do
that for you over on the right we see
some other spinners those are for your
existing tables which have started
copying over and that's what I'm gonna
come back up and show hopefully finished
in a little bit but we can see some of
the progress there by going over to the
tables list page alright so this says
we've got the one table with all this
data and it's copying and you can expand
this to show it's state in each cluster
it's copying in all of them right now
these are gonna turn into progress bars
there's one right now so at one percent
all of these are eventually going to
start going and hopefully they should
all be green later on but another thing
that I mentioned right is do you have to
stop your traffic while this is going on
is it unsafe to keep writing and the
answer is no and to show that I've
actually got a loop running already
which is writing victory in two row
Athens in this table and you can see
that here right all of us is going to
the original cluster and even as these
new
cluster's come online if we go back to
the slide alright we've got and can we
go to the next one
we've got default routing right this
comes out of the box you don't have to
do anything if you don't tell us what to
do
we are going to keep your traffic
flowing as it always has to the original
cluster in your instance and this is so
that you don't have to make any changes
to set this up right all your existing
apps keep working and these new copies
are essentially backups until you tell
us otherwise
so all these rights are going into the
original cluster and stash oh there's
nothing at my sleeve I'm gonna show you
the command that I ran and this is a
simple loop over the CBT command-line
it's got to doing a set for a demo table
row Athens the demo column family equals
victory so I'm gonna start running that
again and that's gonna go the whole time
and then when I come back we're gonna
count how many times this wrote into the
original cluster and we're gonna count
how many times it wrote into one of the
new copies and they should be the same
because we're keeping the data in sync
and so with that I'm gonna hand things
back to Carter hello alright thanks doc
okay so we got that kicked off we'll
come back later and do some fun things
with this new global cluster global
instance we have setup all right so I'm
gonna talk a little bit about what is
cloud BigTable and how does it work and
what do you actually use it for so so
first let me get into the replication
thing that we're talking about here so a
year ago we announced a regional
replication which allowed you to put
multiple clusters into a single region
so you could have it used to be a zonal
service and now you could have two zones
two clusters running in separate zones
in a single region and this gave you a
few benefits it gave you an extra nine
on your SLA by expanding your failure
domains it allowed users to isolate
serve and analytics workloads and some
presenters have actually talked about
how they do that Spotify does this a bit
where you can say have one cluster that
is serving low latency traffic to your
customers
and you never cluster that you're
pounding with a MapReduce or
or dataflow job and just beating it up
essentially you can have isolation so
they're not interfering with each other
to that point you can also independently
scale the clusters so you could scale up
your batch cluster to make that go
faster well that's happening and you
keep your keep your serve cluster at a
different level and it also provides if
you're using the the application profile
that supports this then you could then
you would get automatic failover so if
one zone failed all your traffic would
automatically go to the other zone so
today we're announcing is that you have
global replication and there's two main
changes with this this allows you one
you get to replicate between four zones
not two and it completely removes the
restriction in what region those zones
are in so as I mentioned before you
could put you know you could put one on
the east coast or the west coast you
could put two you know you could have a
Japanese cluster you have one at azekah
one in Tokyo and then you can also fan
these out around the globe and I'll talk
a little bit about you know why might
use some of these different things
alright so a big table itself there's
main reasons to use big table is speed
and low latency so it's a very high
throughput system and these this
throughput is nice and linearly scalable
we did a presentation a couple of years
ago in fact with where we demonstrated
that BigTable could handle if we threw
three thousand nodes up and were able to
get thirty million QPS durable writes
and 30 gigabytes per second and that
wasn't that was far from the peak of
what we could actually pull off on the
system the other thing that you get
while with this account remarkable thing
is there's other ways you can do very
high speed ingestion but the trick about
BigTable is why you're blasting this
data in the split second or a split
nanosecond after we acknowledge you're
right it is immediately accessible for
reads and it's right the read latency is
very low so a single-digit millisecond
latency so if you're using flash maybe
three to four milliseconds HDD maybe a
couple of milliseconds more and then but
generally the long tail itself stays
within about ten milliseconds and that's
a that's a nice set of characteristics
and then with this you get a very linear
scalability so
the knob you use on BigTable now the
only knob we give you forget for
configuration is nodes so you start with
three is your basic production cluster
and then you can scale it up from three
to ten to 300 and as mentioned we've
gone as high as 3,000 before and the
thing that's kind of nifty about
BigTable is the scale the scalability
curve is actually linear well beyond you
know from 30 at least to the 30 million
point and that's pretty nifty because
usually these curves start to flatten
out a little bit over time the
internally we've optimized the
bottlenecks enough where it goes linear
way beyond these bounds essentially and
this is valuable for planning in terms
of thinking about how many nodes you're
going to need for a different load you
don't have to test it out you can once
you get certain sample loads that are
representative you know get a good sense
of what what size cluster you would need
to handle say 10x that 100x then it's
also good for business purposes because
if your business is attached to the
amount of operations that you're having
on your BigTable then you could predict
cost of revenue and that's useful so
part of the way that BigTable does this
is it abstracts out the storage from the
actual processing layer so your BigTable
nodes are essentially they're kind of
quasi stateless things that sit on top
of the actual storage system which is a
filesystem called Colossus which is a
newer generation system that replaced
our earlier Google file system and the
nodes are responsible for making sure
that the data is there to be read
quickly so it's holding on to the
indexes in memory and it's also
channeling your data through to make
sure you're getting that really nice
write throughput but by keeping them
separate you can do some cool things
like we can do really aggressive
rebalancing which we do so imagine the a
over there represents a a single chunk
of data and this Chuck of data is
getting a lot of activity maybe it's a
pattern that crops up every day at 2:30
in the afternoon and what BigTable will
do is will say okay so a is getting hot
so I'm gonna start I'm gonna start
moving things off of this node so this
node can serve more of the a traffic
essentially
and BigTable does this fairly quickly it
checks these patterns every couple of
minutes or so and just keeps rebalancing
does this all day every day so even as
patterns go change throughout the day
BigTable will come back and keep
readjusting the same patterns as it sees
them you know day in day out another
advantage is you get very very easy
resizing very fast resizing so if you're
familiar with other systems like
Cassandra and things like that where you
have to deal with re-indexing resizing
is kind of a pain on a lot of these
those systems here you can just throw
nodes at it the the nodes will be
available in seconds it'll take several
minutes for us to rebalance to get the
maximum kind of bin packing of your your
load onto these nodes and then you know
you can do some cool things with this so
one is when it's good for operational
issues surprise traffic just throw some
nodes at it another could be at the end
of the week maybe you have a large batch
process which takes ten hours and you
wish it would took take one hour so you
just you know up your cluster by 10 X
run your batch load and then spin it
back down again okay so here's a few
different use cases so one is at tech so
Google is has a little bit of ADD tech
inside our company and we do a lot of
this stuff on top of BigTable it's a low
latency system which is nice and what
you can do is you can use global
replication to put your data where your
users are so BigTable is already low
latency as I mentioned but then if you
can actually put your data close even
closer to your customers then that can
shave off milliseconds of native network
traffic so in this example we have a
zone set up on the East Coast the west
coast and central US another example is
financial services and this gets to the
disaster recovery situation I was
talking about you could set up a couple
of zones to be your primary high
availability service pretty close to
Wall Street you're not going to do high
frequency trading on this but it's good
enough for back-office operations and
things like that it's still going to be
very fast and very high throughput and
then we've got a South Carolina zone
that's about 400 miles to the south and
so you could set that up
and we will just be replicating your
data there if you have a problem you
know if North Korea jeanja goes down
there's a hurricane or whatever then we
will automatically fail over to South
Carolina or if you prefer we can have a
manual Phil over to you South Carolina
and your recovery point objective is
going to be measured in minutes in the
worst case and that'll be the long tail
of the replication latency most of your
data will be there in just seconds in a
replication time objective if you're
doing automated failover I'll write
filler County measured in seconds the
third case I mention and the third case
I'll go into detail on is IOT so we have
a lot of customers who use us for
telemetry storage there's actually a lot
of industrial IOT cases there's a as a
cool company called cotton night which
uses us for we all platforms and
shipping go you know go check them out
on the on the expo floor it's pretty
neat in this case I'm getting an example
of commercial IOT where imagine you have
a mobile phone app maybe that collects
data on exercise habits and you want to
have a conversation essentially with
your customer you're getting telemetry
data from the customer you want to
process that data give them advice back
if you just have your data in the u.s.
then you're gonna have a poor experience
for everybody else in this case you
could throw one cluster in each of your
four different in four different
continents and be close to customers all
around the world essentially low latency
everywhere and then you could have your
data you could do your analytics in a
single place so imagine you make your
Iowa cluster a little bit bigger and
that's getting all the data from all the
other four court continents and then
you're running maybe longer daily batch
processing on that data as well so other
use cases for cloud big table we have
gaming customers again the low latency
is there's nice getting of being able to
get a lot of data from a lot of users
that high right throughput is useful
it's a big data system so genome
sequencing is another use case for
BigTable and then energy utilities in
telecom all have variations of things
that work well for BigTable geospatial
data again things that often look like
the IOT use cases I was looking talking
about before as well
but to make all this work you have the
software as cloud BigTable but you know
we're kind of glossing over the fact
that the data has to actually move
between these different places and
that's actually really the hard part so
and you need to make this network work
it has to scale has to handle immense
amount traffic removing you know ten
terabytes here we can move a lot more
than that actually and it needs to be
cost-efficient your business needs to be
able to afford it and it needs to be
available all the time so to make this
work we have a we have a special network
and Sabari is going to talk about the
network and the software that makes this
possible so specially
good afternoon everyone I'm chef Ashley
and I'm going to talk about network that
supports this kind of applications so at
Google we believe network is a key
differentiator when it comes to building
an application that's scalable and
available so Google has been investing
quite a bit in this technology for over
a decade the network infrastructure team
in Google have been building unique
network infrastructure especially driven
by Google's needs Google's compute and
storage infrastructure needed something
that didn't exist in the industry so we
built unique and innovative products and
many of them have been published as
research papers and they have influenced
the industry the academia but most
importantly they have served Google's
applications the essential applications
that have over billion users like search
Gmail YouTube and going forward the same
infrastructure is going to be available
for our Google our cloud customers who
can build their products and that so
this is a snapshot of Google cloud
network the locations here at cloud
regions current and future ones
and not all of them are cloud BigTable
regions yet the footprints keep growing
and I would like us to focus on the
dense graph that connects these
locations there are plenty of
terrestrial links as well as lot of
transoceanic links and these
transoceanic links are quite interesting
we will talk about those little more in
details some of these transoceanic links
Google actually have invested in for
example you can see there is one from
Florida to Brazil it's called money
cable system that's operated by Google
along with few other telecom companies
we'll talk more about those so talking
about the density of the graph that
reflects the sky
and availability of the network so the
application like the one we are going to
demonstrate is not running on public
Internet it's running on a private
global backbone that's run by Google so
every packet traverses router that's
controlled by Google and one of the
catastrophic failures in a normal
network is fiber cut that causes
partition and that causes system
inconsistencies etc are quite rare in
this kind of scenario so many of these
regions are actually hosted in our
massive data centers and each data
center by rule has at least three
different fibers that connects it to the
global network which means fiber cut
which is often treated as a catastrophic
failure is not a catastrophic failure in
this case and yet another example is the
transatlantic connectivity as you can
see there are six different fiber routes
that connects our North American regions
to our European regions what does that
mean that definitely talks about scale
each of these fibers can carry several
terabytes per second of traffic and
there are six of them and we expect them
to fail independently which means we can
provide stricter bandwidth guarantee
over these links across the ocean and
next I'm going to show you a little bit
of the behind-the-scenes story how this
is built so this is a cartoon view of
one of those six transatlantic cables
that connects Virginia to London and
this is of course not drawn to scale I
have a sample cable for you you see you
can come and take a look after the
presentation so it's probably not as
thick as you would imagine I can wrap my
fingers easily around it and at the
centre of this cable there is the
optical fiber that carries the signal as
pulses of light I also have a spool of
25 kilometers of fiber take a look at it
if you want later so each of these
fibers it's made of glass very high
quality glass with no impurities
whatsoever and each of these fiber
strand it's approximately as thick as a
strand of hair but it can carry 100
terabytes per second of data what does
that mean 100 terabytes per second would
translate to something like 10 million
streaming YouTube videos and as you can
see the thickness of the cable gets
thicker gets wider near the shore
because it's high risk for damage and
these are laid out using ships you can
see a carbon version of that sometimes
there are two ships coming from two ends
and in the middle of the ocean the cable
is lifted off the ocean floor and
spliced and bedded back into the oceans
bed we'll see a video soon and we lay
out these paths we survey the path
earlier so that we avoid rough Terrence
and coral reefs hungry sharks so we'll
see them in a bit
so what that is not the first thing that
will come to mind when you talk about
networking however this is for a large
chunk of our network lives not in the
data centers data centers do have a
piece though and even though we don't
think about what are but two thirds of
the earth's surface is covered with
water which means we cannot build a
network around the globe without laying
cables under these water bodies the
network is slow but people have been
laying out these cables for a long time
for over 150 years and these were not
for this kind of data network it was for
telegraphy what has changed more
recently is what goes inside these
cables so we'll see in a bit how these
cables are constructed and how they are
laid out specially with the example of
mo'ne cable system so in the center of
the cable we have the glass fiber this
is a typically color-coded Y if we want
to repair we want to splice blue with
blue and red with red and these are used
for identification and these are
typically allocated pairwise one in each
direction transmit and receive and of
course there are a lot of protective
layers there is one player that is very
special
that's the copper layer because it's not
just for protection it's used for
carrying power to the repeaters that sit
along the path and after with all these
letter layers it's now ready to be
buried under the sea floor and if any of
you happen to visit the Sunnyvale office
we have a model of one of these boats
feel free to check it out what about
them
maybe we train them actually to speak
the truth
the Sharks do bite these cables once in
a while but with all the protective
layers they do not really damage the
cables or cause an outage so we cannot
really blame them now back to how this
network is used so one key observation
is that there is lot more traffic
between servers than a server and an
user and the inter server traffic is not
only high in volume it's also has a very
different characteristics it's more
bursty there's no smooth diurnal pattern
and more amenable to classification
there's so much of this traffic that we
built a whole separate backbone we call
it before that's our back-end backbone
that connects our data centers and
people say developers at Google get to
use wide area network just like people
get to use local area network in other
places
thanks to before but this privilege
should not be limited just to Google
developers with cloud offerings like
cloud BigTable this network would be
available to our users or cloud users as
well so what does it take to build a
network like this scale is of course a
very challenging goal and everything at
Google has to be built at scale and in
presence of scale other goals also
become challenging one thing to note
here is that as our compute scales
Network scales quadratically because of
its source disk pairwise nature which
means unit cost does not necessarily go
down unlike computer storage and
availability of course is a is our final
goal without availability the bandwidth
makes no sense so I'll talk about two
approaches that we take to build a
network like this one is a hardware
approach and one is a softer approach
so in terms of hardware we do not use a
lot of expensive feature redraw and
feature-rich routers we use cheap
commodity hardware we mesh them and
build big switches so super gate is our
regional network that we use in most of
our data centers to connect zones within
the region and pair with other regions
and it delivers 1.6 petabytes per second
of non blocking capacity and 1.6
petabytes per second would translate to
few hundred million streaming videos and
that's all within a region and this
picture shows one of the eight building
blocks of super gate it's built with a
few hundred cheap commodity switches
meshed to provide two thousand ports
each with hundred gig capacity so this
hardware piece of the solution and on
the software side we follow a philosophy
called software-defined networking
technology the main idea is to take the
smarts out of the network and run them
in servers that are available in
traditional network routing and control
software typically runs on the CPU that
leaves inside the routers which is
limited so for us these get to run on
Google servers powerful Google servers
and we get to leverage all of Google's
distributed computing infrastructure as
a result we can run advanced
optimization algorithms pretty fast and
utilize all the links that have been
deployed optimally that means our
network is more efficient and also
because of the good compute
infrastructure the algorithms converge
faster which means if there is a fiber
cut the network converges fast so that
produces high availability it's much
faster compared to traditional MPLS RSVP
textile networks so with all these what
have we achieved so the graph on the
Left shows how the scale of our network
has grown in recent
five year period the traffic has grown
by two orders of magnitude and at the
same time actly actually the last year
of that period we have measured
availability and it has gone up by at
least one nine one nine actually
translates to 10x improvement in
unavailability so an hierarchical
control system based on Software Defined
Networking allowed us to do this with
that I am going to wrap up we are not
done yet the network continues to evolve
because Google believes Network is a key
differentiator and we have to continue
to evolve and invest in it we are not
only delivering new features as needed
by our customers which use Google
applications and cloud applications we
are growing in scale we continue to
innovate upgrade in place and we
continue to improve scale availability
and decrease cost with that I'm going to
hand it over to thanks exa gosh we won
1.6 petabytes per second is pretty
Bunker's isn't it all right so we learn
about how the software-defined network
and all this fiber that we own or you
know we're share some so and so we share
allows us to have the scale the
cost-effectiveness and the availability
to provide the data locality around the
world for a solution like BigTable so
we're going to do now is we're gonna go
back to Doug all right I'm gonna pray to
the demo gods and let's see if see how
we're doing
so I'm smiling the last one finishing 10
seconds ago the other two have been done
for a bit so just to remind what we were
doing right we are running writes yeah
there we go we're running writes through
default routing writing victory into
Athens and that's going to the original
cluster in Oregon and we have
replication set up now
between these four regions around the
world so if we cut back to the there so
you can see these are all done we're
waiting at a local pass to collect disk
usage on this one because it just
finished but everything is all set up
replication is running so next thing
we're gonna do I'm just gonna throw over
to the monitoring page to show that
we've been writing the whole time and
then we're gonna kill these rights right
they've served their purpose and we're
gonna see how many times this right
happened in the original cluster so we
can sort of check for consistency here
so gonna run this command here this is
again the CBT command-line tool it's
pointed at this table that's doing a
lookup now into demo table four row
Athens I'm gonna grip for victory and
I'm gonna count the lines that come back
and we've got 30 115 so now what we want
to do is see if that's the number
somewhere else but like I said this
default routing if we don't tell where
to send the request it's gonna go to
this original cluster so we need to set
some routing rules up to do that I'm
gonna go over here into the app the
application profiles page this is a cool
feature I'm going to talk a little bit
more in a second but just to keep things
going we're gonna create one of these
these let you control your routing in a
fine-grained level and so I'm gonna
create one called check copy give a
little description and I'll point this
at say the Asia clusterings this is c4
and I'll create it and all this is is an
ID that you've set up with the server
and then when you send this ID with a
request we will route things as you set
up for that ID so we've created the new
profile here you can see the old one the
default and that's rounded at c1 which
is the original thing and now we just
run this command again all we have to do
is add at profile equals check copy run
it again and we should get 31:15 again
and there it is so even though we were
writing before during and after these
copies write replication has kept this
data in sync it took probably only about
two seconds for this to come across
which is sort of a typical 99th
percentile number that we generally see
for these sorts of setups especially
since there's not a lot of traffic here
to begin with
so replication at the heavy-lifting I
just want to talk about app profiles for
a little bit and then I'll show a
monitoring graph just takes a little
while to load that shows that this
actually routed where we said it did so
app profiles like I said are an ID that
you set up in advance and I want to plug
these to people who are looking into
replication I also want to plug these
for people who are just using BigTable
and not ready for application yet all
right all in that profile is is a way to
slice your traffic we provide some
config on the server side to let you
control routing but even if you don't
need that it still gives you her
application monitoring so you can see
for example how much traffic is coming
from your batch job versus your
streaming ingestion versus your you know
live traffic surfing reads and you know
that's a useful feature on its own in
addition if you set up one of these per
app if you do want to adopt replication
it gives you a fine grain way to just
move over one app at a time when it's
ready for replication and everything
else will just do what it was doing
before and the best part about that is
you can just reroute it from here you
don't have to down your app or change
any code right you just change the
server-side config and we'll reroute
everything for you so hopefully I've
convinced you and hopefully I've also
talked long enough for this to finish
loading so if we just go over to
monitoring again alright so we see one
read here looks like we did not quite
have enough time to see the other read
come in so I'll return to this later I'm
gonna jump over to another instance now
and show you some disaster recovery this
is something that Carter lead to before
right and this is something that
replication makes very easy
so if we can go over to the slides just
show a nice diagram of what we're gonna
do and go a couple forward so the new
setup that we have in this instance is
we've got a primary serving cluster in
Iowa u.s. central and we've got a backup
cluster in Oregon and we've also got a
load generator running in Iowa and it's
using failover
or any cluster routing this goes nearest
first so whichever cluster is close
that's what we're gonna use and we will
only try the other one if it's if the
first request is slow or air is out for
some reason and so you can see here the
traffic by default is all gonna go right
back into Iowa where it started so if we
cut back to the demo you can see that
that's exactly what's happening we've
got these two clusters and right there
you see that all that 20,000 writes per
second they're all going to the served
cluster and none of them are going to
the backup right now another thing that
I want to point out is that the backup
is smaller right the backups not taking
any live traffic and the replication
load that we're sending to it is a
little bit more efficient because we can
kind of batch and window things behind
the scenes so even though it has 1/3 the
compute power of the serf cluster it's
still able to keep up which is all it
has to do it's just trying to keep this
hot swap a hot swappable copy of the
data live so from there we're gonna go
back to the Edit instance page and we're
gonna simulate what happens if that serf
cluster goes down right imagine there's
a lot of fiber cuts or there is a
tornado you know a big outage in the
zone that makes most or all of your
requests start failing I'm gonna
simulate this by just deleting the serve
cluster and this is something that I
encourage people to try themselves if
they're using replication for this
purpose because it lets you sort of get
a feel for what you need to do in the
event of a failover situation so you can
see already I don't know if anybody was
looking at the CPU before the CPU is
already going up in the backup cluster
this is going to update in a little bit
the writes per second but behind the
scenes
what's happening is everything is
rerouting it only takes a few seconds
for this to happen it takes longer
unfortunately for the metrics to
actually show up on the screen but so
imagine this did happen right let's
actually let's just go back to the slide
so we can get a nice picture of this and
go to the next one right this is going
to route everything to Oregon now if
this actually happens there are a few
things going on right in this case the
cluster is gone but if the cluster we're
still there and throwing errors every
request is going to take a little bit of
time to realize something's up and fell
over so that's going to add a little bit
of latency and the fact that it has to
go further is also going to add a little
bit of latency but the requests are
still going to get served eventually so
this is a graceful degradation situation
a couple things that you want to deal
with here number one you might want to
sort of cut out that fell over latency
so in the real world the other cluster
is still there it's throwing errors
you'd want to try to delete it if the
zone is really completely inaccessible
you might not be able to but it's a good
practice to try that out first and then
the next thing that you're gonna want to
do is size up the backup clustering
Carter mentioned this is very easy to do
and all you have to do again is click a
couple buttons and this is because we've
provisioned it lower for cost-saving
purposes but now it's actually taking
the full traffic and so we're gonna want
to make it bigger so that it can handle
the throughput without falling behind
request will be served a little slower
but they won't knock the cluster over
right and that's already done and in the
next few minutes we're gonna start
rebalancing the load and you see the CPU
utilization go down now hopefully again
those graphs take a little while to load
but hopefully we can see already the
initial failover from this going on yeah
so right here you can see traffic
falling off a cliff to the surf cluster
and traffic coming up to the backup
cluster it's not quite all the way to
where it was and that's a consequence of
that extra latency but the failover is
working and so once you've sort of
handled the immediate emergency things
are still in the degraded State we're
gonna do what we did in the other demo
and we're just going to add another
cluster this
replication someplace else that's
working so we can add a cluster say if
it's just a zonal outage the original
one was in US central 1b we can add a
cluster in US central 1c and it will be
copied in the time that it takes to come
up and talk about networking and that'll
spin for a bit and then it'll be done
so that's failover I just want to check
back over here and see if I yep so this
is the original demo just showing that
that second read request went to the
other cluster and that's it we had
things back to Carter alright thanks
Doug
so back to the slides here so just to
wrap up you get with the failover
solution we saw that we're able to get
fast global access to a single data set
we copied terabytes of data in just
minutes we do basically heavily
paralyzed rights over this massive fiber
network so we're actually able to copy a
lot of data in a short amount of time
and it's so fast as you as you notice
like one of the things we're talking
about is hey we need you we need an
extra cluster in our instance let's just
spin up another one on the other side of
the continent and just copy the data
there and that's actually something that
works pretty well you get a disaster
recovery out of the box scaling up
scaling down takes seconds and you can
reroute individual applications you use
use application profiles configure each
different application use a different
profile even if they're all using the
same routing rules that gives you a lot
of flexibility operationally to decide
what you want to do with traffic
so in summary with global data
replication you get a global presence so
you basically a global local presence
essentially you get the the low latency
of being local but that data is kept in
sync around the entire world in seconds
typically and on minutes in the long
tail you have single-digit milliseconds
latency as I mentioned it's a very high
scale system we haven't found anyone who
can push it beyond its limits yet if you
think you can let us we want to
talk to you and he have a out-of-the-box
disaster recovery solution with this as
well
[Music]